fiery start of a 12-year mission to Pier
below ice on another world
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer or juice
is looking for alien oceans that might
Harbor life
it will study Callisto Europa and
Ganymede three of the biggest moons
orbiting the nearest gas giant to Earth
as well as Jupiter itself
we can say that Jupiter is like a
Minnesota system imagine that Jupiter at
its Center is like the star and then the
icy moons like the planets
scientists believe each hides a dark
Ocean 100 kilometers deep or more
beneath the pockmarked icy surfaces
on Earth Jupiter is one of the brightest
objects in the night sky
these moons are visible through a basic
telescope
but it's 600 million to 1 billion
kilometers away from Earth and getting
there without relying on its own fuel
means juice needs the gravitational pull
of several planets including our own to
pick up enough speed
after leaving Earth it's planned that
juice will make one orbit around the Sun
and then return a few months later to
use the gravity of both Earth and the
moon to gain more speed Venus will give
it a push in August 2025 before it again
passes Earth in 2026 and 2029 it'll then
travel at top speed toward Jupiter
that'll catch it in 2031. it will have
four years to find and measure the
oceans our instruments is a reader a low
frequency reader that as the focus on
the analysis of the subsurface of the
icy moons so we look into the mysteries
of the subsurface because we can
penetrate for about nine kilometers
magnetometers will measure how these
oceans move
juice will map materials on the moon's
surfaces in detail and take photographs
it will spend most of its time in orbit
around Ganymede a rare Moon that has its
own magnetic field
s
juices find habitability
life it means
of life but that would be a huge step
the pioneering mission is due to end in
July 2035. by then juice will be
withered by Jupiter's harsh radiation
and crash into Ganymede mission
accomplished Colin Baker Al Jazeera